the Joe Rogan experience probably nobody
knew what like a star was a new thing
right right like I played this video
yesterday Jamie sent me I put it on my
Instagram of Elvis doing karate and it's
a crazy video and you watch Elvis do
this like nonsense karate yeah and he's
so obviously pilled out of his mind
so obviously hi that you're what you're
watching it you're thinking we're not
playing this right what when you don't
even play the volume but what so when
you're watching this and Elvis is going
through all this you realize oh this guy
was one of the very first real
superstars again there was no Road map
how have this guy learned how to behave
yeah I mean look at him he's smiling
high as a kite now check this out look
at this karate stay the guy's just
laying on the ground he stomps on his
stomach he goes knee to belly that's
legit and look at this Clause the eyes
and the mouth at the same time and then
he's there like okay you're done he's
like no no horn oh sorry man I got some
other ideas hold on hold on puts his
hand up nope wah juice stay close I got
some booze all over him that's a karate
move he does all this crazy karate [ __ ]
and then it helps I got a bread belt
better than black belt look at this the
guy throws a punch steps aside I'm gonna
step aside throw a karate kick Wow it's
he does disarming things in that video
too that are pretty funny it's amazing
because all my life I always heard yeah
Elvis was a black belt under Edie Parker
because Edie Parker when I was a kid is
a legitimate karate instructor like
everybody knew who Ed Parker in Los
Angeles boy that's a good question I do
not know where he was originally but I
know he had I believe yet places all
over the country well your guy yeah he
grew up
he grew up out here yeah he he went to
but I think Edie Parker had a chain like
do you remember when we were living in
Boston it was Fred Volaris do you
remember Fred Villiers karate studios
that Fred Volare self-defense studios
they were everywhere they're everywhere
they're all over the place and what they
had basically done is figured
how to teach karate in like a digestible
form that like families could go to and
it just became this big business but
Edie Parker was thought of as like super
legit like that was one of the guys like
there's a few guys you know those
American karate people this of American
martial arts people is Dan Inosanto
there was you know Bob wall there was
Eddie Parker like he was a legit guy and
I always thought that Elvis was legit
well I never seen until that video I'd
only seen like a couple of things like
him on stage throwing kicks that was
crit two punches at the end is the
craziest because they're nowhere near
the guy's head I like guy's hands are
taped up to gonna paper hands off my own
mirror this guy was gonna throw kick I'm
sure you go ahead tour kick yeah
try it again like like he's got a
[ __ ] shirt with a collar on
underneath his karate gig look at that
karate chop sipping their blocks away
walk away man walk away Elvis Presley
what does it say gladiators project 1974
please God come at me like this I'm
Taylor now I'll just grab your arm and
that guy he's like a real karate guys
like this is [ __ ] look he's clawing
at the hands always ahead it's got a
head yanking Oh elbow him there oh man
I'm get him right here hit him in the
back he's like making [ __ ] up as he goes
along I'm all elbow him right in the
face elbow always got a gun
[ __ ] that gun I'm a karate you Wow but
to that guy I mean the the level of fame
that he had achieved was unfathomable I
mean no one no one no one had any idea
what that was and then my fantasy I mean
you know marrying how old was Priscilla
14 or not she's very young and and just
oh yeah right now here man I chop your
ear I'm gonna get behind him because a
lot of people lay behind you and they're
attacking you get behind them I'm just
look out come on show a touch palm
strike to the head try to get me with a
gun good luck good luck along pills he
was on pills for long oh yeah he's on
pills right now yeah he's loving life
look at that look at that school where
yeah he's gotta go but I don't give a
[ __ ] cuz they're gonna gum up my hand
and he's gonna stay put I'll get my hand
right up in his head come on peanut burn
Delano sandwich there's no way he didn't
accidentally punch those guys in the
face constantly darn probably did you
know they're probably mad at them
[Applause]